Hello and welcome to this video on Editor Asset Utilities.
In this we will be doing an exercise where we will be making a mass asset renaming tool.
Ok, let's jump into the editor and we're going to create a new asset.
So if you right-hand click, if we come up to Editor Utilities, this time let's select
the Editor Utility Blueprint.
This is going to give us a number of different choices.
We are going to select an Asset Action Utility.
And I'm going to call this S-A-A-U underscore rename.
And I'm going to double click to open this up.
Again this will look a little bit like the blueprints we've previously been working with.
But one of the things you might notice is we have no viewport in this situation.
We do not need them.
Now an Asset Action Utility works a little bit like a code library.
So we could write a number of different functions and these would be available anywhere in the
content browser by right clicking on the appropriate assets.
The first thing we're going to want to do is create a new function.
And I'm going to call this Rename.
So what I'll do is I will select the purple node.
And you can see over on the right hand side we have options for input.
I'm going to hit once and I'm going to call this the Free Fix.
And this is going to be of the type String.
And I'm going to add another one.
And this is going to be the Post Fix.
So this function is going to take in two variables, Prefix and Postfix.
And we're going to just put the prefix before the name of any of the assets we're going
to change and the Postfix we're going to put after it.
So let's write some code.
So the first thing that we're going to do is drag off and we're going to want to get
selected assets.
What this is going to do is it will return an array of any of the assets which you have
selected within the content browser.
So say I came up into here.
I'm going to reduce this just down to materials.
If I selected these four materials, it would return an array with these four materials.
And I come in here and I will do a for each loop.
Now all I want to do is rename the asset that we have here.
If I type in rename asset.
So whatever I would input here is going to be the new name of the asset.
We want this to be a string concatenation of our inputs and the actual name.
So I'll drag off of this and I'm going to type in append.
And I'm going to add an extra pin by clicking on the add pin here.
Now I'm going to get the object name.
I'm going to connect that up to the B pin.
And I'm going to grab the prefix and put it in the first pin and the post fix and put
it in the C pin.
Now this is our entire code at this point.
So all we're doing is getting the selected assets that we have.
And for each of them, we're going to rename them, putting the prefix at the beginning
and the post fix at the end.
And if I now hit compile and save, and then if I jump back to our asset browser, let's
do this with one to start with.
So we've got our basic floor.
If I right-hand click on this, you can see that we now have an option for scripted asset
actions.
And next to them, they've got the option for rename.
If I click on this rename, I'm going to get a pop-up box.
It's going to ask me for a prefix and it's going to ask me for a post fix.
And so I'm going to call, I'm going to say this is pre underscore and I will do underscore
post on the other side and click OK.
Now because this is in alphabetical order, we've now lost it.
If I was to search for pre, you can see we have pre, m, basic floor and post.
So that's working.
Now the other nice thing about this is we could come in and we could select, let's select
all of these assets.
We could select as many assets as you wanted.
Right-hand click and under asset scripted actions, rename.
And I'm going to call this.
A underscore and at the end, I'm going to do the underscore and hit OK.
You can see now all of these assets have been updated in one quick go.
The main reason why these asset action utilities are really useful is because they'll
automatically appear when you right-hand click and select the assets in the browser.
And I could create numerous ones.
So if I just added another one, for example, and I change this to be hello.
And I print string hello and compile, save, jump back in.
Right-hand click, you see under scripted actions, we now got hello as well.
Hello appears in the top left hand corner.
So the trigger, and that's the main thing, the trigger for this is going to be on the
scripted asset actions.
Now what you might find is that you actually want these options to only appear for a
specific class and you can do that.
So if I was to come up here and I was to select class defaults, we have a list here
of supported classes.
If I was to push plus, I could select to only show this on materials.
And now these options would only appear for materials or classes that are children of
materials.
So, for example, if I was to grab this, just control P, right-hand click, the
scripted asset options would not appear here.
However, if I was to jump to the material, right-hand click, you'd see that we do have
the scripted asset actions here.
So you can see how that's a really useful tool to just very quickly create tools that
can run against a lot of different things.
Now, say you wanted to do the same thing and add a menu option in, but this time for a
actor rather than an asset.
Let's just demonstrate that quickly.
So if I come into here again, I come to editor utilities and I select an editor utility
blueprint.
Now it's not any of these.
What I actually need to search for is if I search for utility, you can see that we have
actor action utility here.
I'm going to select that and I'm going to call this act action utility example.
If I double click on this again, if I just create another function and I'm going to call
this hello and I'll drag off here, search for a print string.
Hello.
Compile save.
Now, if I select our chair, right-hand click, you will see here at the bottom, we have
scripted actor actions.
I can just select that as hello.
Now, say we wanted to get hold of the selected actors.
So if I delete this, grab one of these and I go get selection, get selection set.
That is going to return us all the selected actors.
So I could do a for each loop.
Like that.
And all I'm going to do is I'm going to destroy these actors.
So this is a quick way to go and destroy everything that you've selected.
Of course, you could just press delete, but this is a good example of how you can
implement something on an entire selection set.
So I'm going to go ahead and delete this.
I'm going to go ahead and delete this.
So this is a good example of how you can implement something on an entire selection set.
So if I grabbed a couple of these.
Right-hand click, come down to scripted actions, do hello, and everything's gone.
So again, it's just an example of how you could create an action and you can do
anything from the trigger.
What's more important is where the trigger is.
So you'll know that if you want to trigger something on a specific asset,
then you could do it using an actor action utility.
Okay.
So that is the last of our examples.
Thank you very much for sticking with us.